so what is the best diet for our
planetary Health we shifted about 80 to
90 percent plant-based diets it would
free up an extreme amount of land we're
talking like areas the size of the
entire continent of Africa that we can
bring wild 50 of all habitable land on
the planet is used for agriculture 83 of
that is used for animal Agriculture and
fish farming there's very little small
farmers anymore there's four companies
in the world that own 99 of all chicken
breeding wow four companies that was
ecologist and environmental researcher
Nicholas Carter here to examine our food
system particularly honing on grass-fed
Dairy and red meat and its impact on the
environment by far the biggest thing we
should be shipping away from is beef and
dairy they're not looking at the bigger
picture look at this pretty farm it's
local I mean put simply I think this is
decades and decades and Decades of
lobbying subsidies and misinformation
this is a story that's been told for
many many years and marketed to look
that way the subsidy issue is so huge
and it's something that I'm very
surprised that political discussions
they're not having that discussion on
either side of the aisle only four
percent of the biomass of all animals on
the planet are wild the rest are humans
and domesticated animals it's a very big
number the biggest driver by diversity
loss is animal agriculture I struggle
with the component of government getting
bigger and stronger and more powerful I
don't love that idea because those are
mostly the drivers of why people choose
to eat what they eat is the price and
the taste this episode is centered
around the implications of our food
choices on the world around us we break
down the regenerative grazing and the
claims made by regeners with agriculture
what are its strengths and weaknesses
the only environmental trade-off you get
when you shift to a model like what will
Harris has is you're reducing the soil
degradation relative to intensive
raising you're not making the soil
better than just rewilding we discussed
the problems with today's industrialized
model any pain
for us with big numbers that puts things
into perspective on which dietary
pattern is optimal to support our
planetary health so what do you think of
the documentary conspiracy then there's
been some stats in that case that were
exaggerated that 51 figure it's
inaccurate our food choices greatly
impacted this planet that we live on and
the more that we can make informed
choices the better and easier it will be
to shift towards a more sustainable way
to live together and Thrive with our
ecosystem not against it if you look at
all agricultural lands 60 of it is you
use for grass-fed beef that's not even
grass finish they're still ending in
like a feedlot but that only returns
back two percent of global calorie
Supply and five percent of protein that
is insane this episode is powerful and
so important I loved this conversation
hope you enjoy it welcome to the Alan
Fisher podcast Nicholas you're here
after the amazing episode that we did on
animal Agriculture and debating it with
Will Harris and Jason Roundtree what are
your thoughts on how that went I have
many thoughts I think uh maybe I'll
start with some of the good I think
there was some great commonality around
stock free organic farming
Jimmy videlli who is with us like his
model affirming which uses compost
doesn't use synthetic fertilizers
doesn't use manure they were on board
with that they they thought that was a
great model
now they were saying you know you do
that model we'll do ours
um and I mean I have lots of other
thoughts too there's just there's so
many things to kind of unpack with how
it went down
I think one of the biggest
inconsistencies throughout the entire
thing was the bigger picture
now I know they didn't really want to
talk about that bigger picture they
wanted to talk about what was happening
on their firm but ultimately we have 10
billion people we need to feed over the
coming couple decades so I think looking
at that bigger picture of what feeds the
most people
what doesn't ruin the planet what
doesn't use more land that's where
there's a lot of issues and throughout
the whole conversation
I think a lot of people might have
noticed I kept asking well how come
we're not calling for at least a little
bit of reduction in animal Source Foods
uh look at the 1960s we farmed about
eight billion animals since that time to
go 60 years it's went up 10 times so now
we're farming over 80 billion land
animals and that's not including fish
there's trillions of fish that are that
are affirmed they're actually even
they're firming it and they're removing
from the ocean and they're measuring it
in tons just because there's so many
so at that scale and how much that's
kind of increased it's only going to get
higher as as populations
gain more income uh that's typically
what happens is they consume a bit more
animal sourced Foods so there's
estimates showing that we would need 120
billion land animals to be killed every
single year to to meet this sort of
demand so anyone working in food anyone
working even if it's on a kind of
specific animal scientist perspective
like Jason Roundtree was to not
understand kind of the basic biophysics
of
you know where food comes from
what's increasing land use what's
increasing methane I mean I don't
believe that he doesn't understand that
I think there's other reasons for why
he's not admitting that
um
it's interesting because it makes
complete sense specifically why will
Harris a farmer would be kind of
frustrated with this conversation
because it's like you're coming at it
with different angles for him he's
saying look what I'm doing with the land
is better than what was happening before
so why are you criticizing it this
should this should be good enough and
honestly he was so sweet like I kind of
wish he was my grandpa he was such a
nice guy and I felt bad how much you
know and you know Jason Round Tree was
also kind and respectful too I felt bad
how much there was like a
um a frustration there where times when
you were speaking about problems within
the bigger picture that he felt like you
were attacking him when really that's
not really not what you were doing so
maybe explain that and also a little bit
more as to why there's such a disconnect
I I think it's bound to happen because
there's lots of different opinions and
perspectives that come into this uh
first of all I was very happy that that
conversation happened I think more of
those conversations need to happen I
think we should not have these kind of
polarizing conversations
um we should be able to discuss things
now that was obviously like you know
recorded and there was there's a
different Dynamic that goes to each
person presenting their their points
forward but I'd be happy to continue the
conversation with them as well
um on or off the mic and
you know I think when doing that you
understand a bit where people come from
you understand what their uh challenges
are
what Financial motivations are involved
uh cultural and social dynamics of why
that happens and you know ultimately
when I was debating will versus debating
Jason there were different conversations
um with will of course he's done better
on his firm versus what was it for he's
kind of shifted away from that
industrial model
which has a lot of problems yeah it's
got a lot of problems I think it's
important though to be clear that will
is not running a small firm it's over
1200 hectares in size and maybe someone
doesn't know what that kind of
translates to that's over 2 000 football
fields so this is a huge Farm
and you know the video that was showed
uh I think he does a good job kind of uh
showing what an industrial firm looks
like with runoff versus his
but when you look at the background of
that picture there's native forest and
there was native Forest before too so if
you're looking back far enough it also
displaced ecosystems and the point I was
making with Will
is if you want to have this model
affirming you're going to need to
decrease animal Source Foods you're
going to need to decrease the production
and consumption and there's ways of
doing that without kind of mandating it
with just making healthy plant-based
Foods more accessible
which hasn't been done really well for
decades so I think um you know when I
push back on him it was mostly around
that perspective because as much as he's
improved some environmental metrics not
all them and certainly not even close to
what it would be for benefits if he were
to to reforce or rewild some of that
land and if you look at Jimmy's model
Jimmy was able to produce a a huge
amount of food on only half half an acre
and he can rewild the rest of that land
and that's what we can do with stock
free organic farming where you're not
using those fertilizers that people are
very adverse to in industrial
agriculture but you're able to also
rewild the land which is what we need to
do and we can incentivize Farmers to
kind of be brought on board with yeah I
think it's a really hard conversation
for him to have with you which I really
admire him for choosing to come on and
have this conversation it's very
admirable and respect respectful
um that he chose to do that I get asked
all the time what skincare products I
use and if you know me at all you know
I'm obsessed with ostea a clean vegan
cruelty free seaweed-based skin and body
care brand that's female founded
providing high performance skincare for
your body so I want to share with you
how I'm updating my easy skincare
routine for fall to keep that hydration
and glowiness on point I'm including
their Plumping hydrating Duo to cleanse
plump and hydrate the skin this Duo
comes with the ocean cleanser and
hyaluronic sea serum I've been using the
ocean cleanser every day for years now
made with ingredients like Bentonite and
a nourishing oil blend you're going to
get addicted to this cleanser it removes
everything from surface impurities to
excess oils has a pH balance formula
that gently exfoliates to unclog pores
without stripping the skin and it
delivers mineral Rich hydration for a
radiant complexion you can see and feel
then I I use the hyaluronic sea serum
made of Japanese miru seaweed which
replenishes and balances the Skin's
natural moisture level for healthy
hydrated skin clinically proven to
instantly increase hydration and
delivers a lifted and firmer look then I
finish with our day glow face oil and
advanced protection cream which I am
obsessed with and right now ostea has an
incredible promotion for you guys when
you purchase the plump hydrating Duo you
save 26 dollars plus I have a discount
code for you guys for an additional 10
off that can be stacked on top of this
deal just enter the code Ellen POD at
checkout you do not want to miss out but
I think it's really hard
to expect a farmer to say look army army
is better than you know the average
farming that you're going to get your
meat but you should eat less of it you
know it's really because it kind of
messes up the entire model of you know
the supply and demand if you want people
to buy your products so that you can
make more money and continue to continue
on it it's pretty hard to for people to
be willing to do that with their
products you know there are some people
that are supportive of regenerative
ranching who do call for reduction in
animal Source foods and uh yeah there is
and uh of those people that are doing
that that's more consistent with where
we need to go and ultimately I wouldn't
be having these conversations and
talking so much about regenerative
agriculture if it at least had that
prerequisite of a reduction because then
you'd be more in line with what would be
feasible and
so with if you look at history of kind
of how ranching
did successfully transition to other
forms of land use there's a few
different kind of solutions you can you
can look to in Costa Rica in the mid 90s
there was a new president a new minister
of environment and they at that point in
time
per land area where one of the leaders
in the world in deforestation and
ranching was a big reason of that
agriculture is a whole but ranching in
Costa Rica was a big driver of ecosystem
damage
so they put something in place it was
quite simple actually and way ahead of
its time they put a 3.5 percent gas tax
um on on all gas and
all that money of that 3.5 was diverted
to Farmers and it was diverted to
Farmers to rewild and reforest the
rainforest essentially and and what they
determined in consultation with the
farmers is what would be that actual
appropriate dollar amount per hectare
they found that they decided on it and
they went from in the mid 90s to leading
in deforestation from ranching to now
winning all kinds of awards for being
one of the most eco-friendly countries
in the world wow that's really
interesting and yeah that just started
with that simple kind of diverting of uh
you know damaging uh gas financing over
to Farmers to help incentivize them to
rewild and before doing that they
basically determined what areas of Costa
Rica are most valuable for for crops and
for tropical fruits and things like that
and kind of allowed that to stay as is
but the rest are able to rewild and uh
typically when you're doing that when
you're shifting away from uh the the
sources of animal consumption and
production that use the most amount of
land you're going to produce more food
you get more protein and calories per
per hectare and that's what that's what
you want to do yeah I love that idea
about using our tax dollars wisely and
it doesn't even have to be that specific
scenario you said where they're adding
something on but I mean that's something
I definitely want our tax dollars to you
to go towards to like supporting our
environment and making this place that
we're stewarding the more habitable to
all of the wildlife around it and just
enriching our Earth you know that's
something I definitely would love to see
my tax dollars going towards and
incentivizing Farmers to switch their
model to something that is more fruitful
for the planet is a great way rather
than just you know creating some kind of
force or anything it's like actually
taking action or even just talking about
it right and hoping that farmers do it
you have to make it feasible for them
because it's not like farming is this
super
um wealth making type of career right so
it has to be something that makes it
easy and accessible for them to do so I
love that idea and what do you think
about your conversation with Jason then
because they're completely different
like you said conversations
so I thought it was gonna be having a
lot more of a scientific debate with
Jason and um that could have
maybe went that way if he were kind of
discussed a bit more of what to talk
about but uh I mean I I quoted
throughout the debate
probably dozens of meta-analyzes lots of
different studies and it was a bit
frustrating that he would classify these
as just like models like kind of like
projections and back of the the paper
calculations when these weren't these
were uh in-depth analyzes of a topic uh
and a meta-analysis is really ultimately
one of the most scientifically
um appreciative forms of determining
what's true now does science have issues
of course like there's all kinds of ways
to manipulate sides but one of the only
studies he cited was a paper from White
and Hall which was among the most
manipulated type of science there was
because what they did is they they
modeled a scenario where people shifted
away from animal Source foods but we did
not reduce the amount of feed crops so
it didn't make any sense in that study
and that study since had all kinds of
replies from academics all across the
world many of course weren't even
necessarily supportive of plant-based
but just saw that this was a like a
model that doesn't make sense yeah
because of course if you're shifting
away from animal Foods you're gonna have
less less crime exactly you're gonna fur
less
um the majority of mono crops right now
are for feed crops and some for biofuels
as well which Jason and I both disagree
that that's a good use of of crops
either but um
one of the kind of bigger picture
scenarios of why animal Source foods are
so much worse is because of feed crops
and I think something that's kind of not
understood well is when you grow say 100
calories of grain
and you feed it to chicken
s determined to be like you know one of
the most efficient use of converting
that feed crop into meat basically
because they're just smaller animals
right but if you take 100 calories of
grain feed it to chicken you're only
going to get about 12 calories back in
meat and that's when they're like
confined too like they're not moving
around much but that's just how much you
lose when you're when you're taking
those crops feeding your chicken uh and
getting meat in the end
um so some of those crops would be
inedible but the majority of it could be
uh edible wheat or grain or soy uh or
corn and when you use so much and you
lose so much of those crops in that
process that's what makes feeding it to
animals such an inefficient use of of
cropland and
um and it uses that much times more
water and land and Etc so I think an
important kind of understanding is that
but then if you look at the kind of the
grazing model that's where you look at
okay well what is grass finished beef
for example use if you look at all
agricultural lands 60 of it is used for
uh for grass-fed beef that's not even
grass spinach they're still ending that
they're still ending in like a feedlot
but that only returns back two percent
of global calorie Supply and five
percent of protein that is insane
let's say we use that 60 of land let's
say we were not you know grazing animals
on it anymore and we did it for plant
agriculture
it would all all the calories would be
directly to the to the humans so you you
would barely need much of that land at
all you could rewild a lot of it uh
right now there's there's been lots of
scenarios that showed if we just divert
the feed crops and the land we're using
for feed crops to to human consumption
we could feed four billion more people
and so that's more than even would be
coming in you know 2050. so we have more
than enough food right now and and we
can continue feeding more people if we
shift more away from animal sourced
foods but like that's why this Narrative
of regenerative ranching is so I mean
incorrect is because we already used so
much land for ranching as is where most
of them are on a feedlot in their life
with regenerative ranching they live
about another another year longer uh
through that process they emit more
methane and then they use more land so
Jason Rountree studied himself where he
did the the analysis of how much land
White Oak pastures uses in their models
it's 2.5 times more land than typical
grass-fed beef I feel like it's the one
it's the one elephant in the room that
they don't want to talk about like it's
the most important piece you know and
will has this you know specific comment
where he says well yes you're right we
will run out of land but we're not gonna
run out of all these other things we're
gonna be the ones doing better with
these other sources what are your
thoughts on that I mean I disagree too
look at water water is is well one of
the most scarce resources that's um
that's increasing with the amount of
drought that's coming uh look at uh
Dairy farming in the American West uh
the the biggest user of water is for
dairy but also for the crops for dairy
so Alfalfa is one of the most kind of uh
water thirsty crops and that's fed to
dairy cows because it's very nutrient
rich and it increases their
um their their production of milk so
um yeah I mean in terms of water use as
well it's it's it's going to be far far
worse if we're shifting towards that
model so we're going to use less and a
lot of people in those scenarios will
say well look at almonds I mean first of
all everyone's eating almonds I mean
it's not like it's not like almonds are
specifically for people that are eating
plant-based of course not yeah so um I
mean right away that's not a good
comparison but looking at uh you know
the main protein foods of uh people are
eating plant-based uh soy different
versions like that they're all using far
less water far less land uh less
cropland to uh and really they're the
only environmental trade-offs you get
when you ship to a model like what will
Harris has is you're reducing the soil
degradation relative to intensive
grazing but you're not you're not making
the soil better than just rewilding and
that's what those that's what the
studies that um I'm pretty sure Jason is
aware of that's what they're not
comparing to they're not comparing to
Wild ecosystems that are nearby and
that's the biggest point to hone in on
because people will say well we have to
eat so we can't just rewild it but
they're missing the point that we would
use far less land if you were using if
you were using that same amount of land
to grow grow crops for people to eat we
wouldn't need that much land if
everybody was doing that we were doing
less animal Foods the amount of land we
would need is significantly less and
you're right A lot of people forget that
when you're talking about this topic of
the environment animal agriculture
versus plant agriculture they forget
that we're growing crops to feed the
animals so when they're talking about
the problems with soy and corn and
everything like that they're not
realizing that the majority of that are
such a large percentage of it is going
towards animal feed we have to feed the
animals in order to get them big enough
to kill them and eat them so what
percentage of crops are being used
towards animal feed specifically like
corn and soy and these other yeah so
with soya of all soil is going towards
animal feed and uh with corn it's about
50 depending on where you're in the
world but it's about that on average
it's at least a third of all crops
overall
so that's huge yeah third of crops
overall are going towards animal feed
that's insane and then even if you're
shifting towards grass-fed you're using
way too much land to make it sustainable
at the rate that we're eating the demand
that we have for animal Foods yeah so in
the UK there's a group called The
sustainable food trust and uh they're a
a group that's incentivized and funded
by animal agriculture the industry as a
whole and they put a report a couple
years ago that said uh soy milk is
destroying the Amazon and it was one of
those ridiculous things I've seen
because uh you know looking at all soy
globally about six percent or even a bit
less is for uh food that people eat wow
so so so little what about at in the
Amazon specifically I mean it's even
less than that it's even lesser than in
terms of what you're growing for soy for
producing uh food for people to eat yeah
you'd never see a commercial being like
the soy grown in the Amazon that's fed
to cattle is is killing the Amazons
Amazon so please eat less cattle yeah
what's happening to the Amazon is very
interesting because there's
um you know in Brazil there's the Amazon
rainforest there's a Serato uh area
which is more like a um Savannah and
grassland but that would be like what's
called like the uh underground Forest
because so much of it grows under the
roots and then there's like the Atlantic
forest and the Amazon is actually uh
kind of Shifting back around where it's
starting to be protected a bit more uh
90 of all land uh at one point in the uh
ninety percent of the the deforestation
in the Amazon was used for branching at
one point so that's the biggest driver
of the Amazon but in the Serato region
which is also an area of the world
that's very very biodiverse and it holds
a good percentage of what you know wild
species are left that area there is
mostly for growing soy and it's mostly
for feed crops for uh mostly Europe and
China the interesting thing that
happened about a few months ago is the
European Union said we're not importing
any more products that are related to
deforestation so a big win what I just
found out though is that didn't include
the Serato region which is not
technically a rainforest but in many
ways you could argue it's as valuable in
that area as a rainforest why is that uh
because there's still a huge amount of
biodiversity
grasslands and Native grasslands that
aren't converted are very biodiverse as
well with different animals that do very
well there a lot of the grasslands that
animals graze on cattle there are
actually a lot of it's like invasive
grasses that they plant there
grass is the cattle tend to tend to
prefer versus the the native things so
even when they're saying that cattle are
just kind of grazing on Native grassland
mostly that's false too most of it is
actually seeded
monocultures you could say upgrass
so um yeah so all to say the Serato
region
uh should be included within this kind
of area that uh would be deforestation
free products and that's where you get a
lot of interest from other countries to
do that as well because really we need
zero more deforestation we need zero
more land that is converted and we're
not going to get that with uh with
shifting to regenerative ranching or or
even at our current rate of animal
Source Foods so we need to kind of
understand that that's a consensus and
then work with people on where they're
at in that and and find ways to shift
away yeah yeah it would have been really
nice if you guys have cut in that debate
episode could have come to the
conclusion that yes we need to shift
towards less animal Foods it seemed like
that would have been a reasonable
request to get to that point but I think
it's really hard to do that when your
whole basis of your career is about eat
our animal Foods because it's better you
know well let's talk about that so Jason
Roundtree he's received 19 million
dollars from uh McDonald's Shell Oil and
Noble Foundation which is the noble oil
Foundation now I brought this up very
briefly in the debate but I knew it
would kind of derailed a bit of the
conversation because people might think
that I'm insinuating that he's biased
because of this money
I think it influences it for sure it
influences him yeah uh and the fact that
that's not disclosed on all of his
studies makes zero sense to me and that
wouldn't necessarily be his fault there
needs to be a lot more accountability
with these journals there needs to be
real kind of academic
um
regulations and academic uh uh kind of
penalties if you don't disclose your
funding a lot of these funders when they
fund certain studies to be done they
hold back a certain amount until they
see the results if they don't like the
results sometimes it's not even
published so
um you know I don't know if that
happened in particular with Jason but
none of his conflicts are listed the
only reason I know that is because there
is a press release on a new funding that
was that was sent to him universities
who's a part of on doing kind of methane
and animal agriculture research what do
you mean that he received that money
like does that go to the college he's
working for yeah it's a combination of
him in the college and the work he's
doing it's you know not going directly
to his pocket but a large part of it
would be he would receive far more
funding from industry than he would from
the University itself
um that's really interesting so like I
mean I've received any money from from
industry on the plant-based side yeah
um you know if ever I do it I want
people to call that out too and uh you
know I think that's something that
it doesn't mean someone is necessarily
saying things that are inaccurate that
they believe to be an actor yeah but
it's one of the kind of things you
should think about whether you determine
something is true or not like who's
paying them to do this uh what influence
is there it's hard because you have to
make a living to do what you love you
know so so there's that that hard
balance of knowing that you know when is
that money influencing what you your the
work that you're doing but if you're
doing work where you have to get to the
truth about something and science it's a
lot different than just oh I'm being
paid to do what I love in a different
way don't you think it's strange though
that they're so opposed to Industrial
agriculture yet
I mean you think of industrial
agriculture McDonald's yeah uh and you
think of General Mills that's industrial
agriculture that's the biggest uh
company that white oak passion sells to
is General Mills so yeah so what do you
think about that how that shouldn't that
at least prove that he's not biased in
that way because McDonald's will
probably want him to favorably produce
an outcome that shows that
industrialized farming animal
agriculture is fine
yeah I mean I don't know exactly what
kind of influence that would have had
but to to then be against industrial
agriculture like they both are to
pretend like it's shifting to this kind
of local small uh animal firm that's not
doing any harm that to me is
misinformation uh bordering on
disinformation like in intent to to
deceive and the reason why I think this
is because
uh methane in particular there's a lot
of new science coming out on methane uh
what the biggest impacts are
um where it's coming from uh there's
just in the last year
there has been a double demand of
satellites launched up in space to
observe down on where methane is coming
from there's a company out of Montreal
Quebec called greenhouse gas
sat ghg sat satellite and what they did
is uh they measured methane over top of
California
and uh based on the isotopic signature
of that greenhouse gas they could
determine where it was coming from
and this was a report that came out
about last year they showed that there
was a large large area of uh concern
that was right above a uh dairy farm
so I love supporting Enigma Mundi
herbals which is my favorite Apothecary
that carries organic wild crafted and
ethically grown Botanicals from
Elderberry syrup and adaptogenic
mushrooms to spirulina chocolate protein
teas and collagen booster powders they
are a super special company that uses
Fair Trade Practices Beyond organic
farming education and small farmers to
create remedies that benefit people from
all walks of life lately I've been
obsessed with their chocolate protein
superfood powder that I add to my
morning smoothies after a workout it's
designed using a blend of mostly South
American roots and seeds traditionally
used for energy strength stamina and
resilience this chocolate protein is a
wonderful addition to your smoothies or
you can even add it to your favorite
baked goods like muffins It's formulated
with pea protein rice protein and
pumpkin seed protein and it tastes
amazing it's adaptogenic energizing and
nutrient dense rich in plant-based
protein Prebiotic rich and may help
regulate blood sugar and assist in
treating adrenal fatigue you guys have
to try this yummy plant protein powder
and they also have so many other REM to
use on their site which are formulated
for beauty immunity mood elevation
stress relief sleep body and spirit and
I find them to be the perfect addition
to my healthy daily routines for my body
inside and out so use my code Ellen 20
for 20 off just click the link in my
show notes to get this deal
a lot of the initial claims around
methane being biogenic and methane not
mattering when it comes from uh animals
and when it comes from uh from a
particular cattle in in Dairy herd that
originates from Jason roundtree's study
which was then picked up from sacred cow
and this documentary and book and they
just run with it and they say methane
from cows doesn't matter
but we're seeing it from space of course
we're observing that it does matter and
we're seeing that signature in space and
then this paired with the different
reports that are saying 32 percent of
all methane come from cattle so if we
reduce this quickly we're going to see
atmospheric effects quickly because it
only lasts in the atmosphere about for
about 10 years and does the methane is
their corn grain fed versus grass-fed
yeah I mean that's what makes it even
more deceiving is typically if they're
grass-fed they'll emit more methane
there's two reasons for this uh one is
when you're feeding cow's grass it's
going to take them longer to get to
slaughter weight so they're living
slightly longer so that's going to mean
a bit more methane in that case but also
uh cattle are
you know their native uh vegetation to
eat would be like grass but it's still a
bit more fibrous so the more fibrous
diet will make them belch a bit more uh
something like bison
uh bison actually does a bit better with
eating grass and don't emit a bit less
methane
um in doing that but not as much as
cattle so when you're shifting from you
know intensive corn feedlots from from
cows to to grass-fed
you're emitting more methane so I mean I
would say if you take those satellites
which there's more and more of them
going up and measuring not just
agriculture but also fossil fuels and
natural gas I think if you measure that
over top of white oak pastures and you
look per cow there would be more methane
coming from there than a feedlot that's
really interesting I would love to see
that I mean we'll see if that is but
that's based on what the science is
showing it's all really interesting
information but I do struggle with the
Assumption of intent because anybody can
do that where they assume that you must
have poor intentions about something
even I get that sometimes where people
say your intentions are I'm like that's
not even my intentions you're just
assuming that so I like to assume that
people have good intentions and that
their biases are just influencing what
they're believing right that to me that
makes more sense at least in regards to
this particular topic that it's easier
to want to run with something that
sounds good as opposed to wanting to
intentionally deceive like you could see
specifically with Will Harris that you
he really believes in his farm and he
really is doing the best that he can he
just seems you know I don't know so
that's where I that's where I land with
the intent thing it's hard to know
someone's intentions and I wouldn't want
to like assume that aspect but I do
understand where you're coming from in
regards to it feels so clear the picture
feels so clear to you so you're like how
what are your intentions here because
like specifically someone like Jason
because you know and he understands the
science and stuff so you're like where
how where does that divide how are you
getting here when you know this about
this but I guess it's just a seeing it
from a different lens potentially or I
mean I like to see the good in people
too yeah totally and um I mean I like to
think that that is what's happening but
I mean if you're this is not necessarily
the case with Will Harris but if you're
Jason rantry you've been working in food
for 20 years or so looking at the
agricultural topic as a whole
um I just
I I'm shocked that he's not able to
admit some basic things that would add
commonality to this entire message and
the fact that he's not able to admit
that which we saw in the debate shows to
me like a big red flag and uh and then
I've seen him with all kinds of others
that are peddling way more
disinformation and clearly highly funded
to do that like he's he's in pictures
with the sacred cow group he's he's
doing
um uh promotion with those that are
pushing some of that narrative far
beyond the science
so I mean I don't want to be with people
that are doing that on the on the
plant-based side yeah I will stay clear
of messages that are uh you know
straying from that scientific consensus
yeah I think there's it's important to
kind of keep pushing and you know being
aware of what different science can show
but also being humble and knowing that
you could be wrong sometimes and you can
kind of shift your opinion based on new
things and based on everything I'm
seeing I'm I'm having a hard time with
that case there yes no I understand
that's totally understandable so what do
you think of here's a plant-based side
the documentary conspiracy then yeah I
mean I've been pretty vocal about how
there's been some some stats in that
case that were exaggerated uh that 51
figure for greenhouse gases
um it's inaccurate okay so what is the
figure then I mean so look at the food
system as a whole the the most logical
uh impacts from greenhouse gases would
be about one-third of all greenhouse
gases come from the food system and the
level of variance is about 25 to 40
percent of all greenhouse gases
um 25 to 42 is what that is and from
that figure there that actually doesn't
include the amount of uh carbon that
could be drawn down
um if you free up land basically because
these like analyzes of greenhouse gas
impacts are looking more like the direct
impacts not necessarily at the uh the
different ways in which you can use land
differently uh so this is kind of what
started me into this topic uh my
master's program in environmental
practice a lot of my thesis work looked
at the different estimates around
greenhouse gas impacts from animal
Agriculture and uh it is underestimated
a lot of the time
uh the most cited figure is 14.5 percent
from the United Nations FAO but that
number is an underestimate it's it's
likely higher than that but then to say
it's 51 or even higher uh there needs to
be far more evidence for that because
it's not showing that at all and I think
in many ways that's kind of devaluing
the real impacts from fossil fuels
um ultimately if we address fossil fuels
if we shift and we decarbonize and we
kind of get off this kind of unlimited
growth Paradigm and also address methane
shifting or also also addressing
agriculture as a whole and shifting more
towards low carbon foods and uh
um kind of sustainable intensification
of plants kind of like the model that
Jimmy videlli was doing with veganic
Agriculture and conservation agriculture
would be another way that's named that
would solve a lot of the environmental
issues if we just addressed those kind
of high level things yeah everything
else can kind of fall into place so then
can you paint a picture for us like the
problems with our farming today both
plant and animal and what we should be
shifting to and not saying you're going
to know how we should do that but what
what it should look like because you're
mentioning Jimmy vedelli and maybe
explaining a little bit more about what
his food system looked like looks like
what he's doing versus what we're doing
on like a wide scale yeah so big picture
fifty percent of all habitable land on
the planet is used for agriculture 83 of
that is used for animal Agriculture and
uh fish farming so uh what we need to do
with our agricultural land globally is
shift to forms of Agriculture that use
less land and can still produce a lot of
food by far the biggest thing we should
be shifting away from is beef and Dairy
uh next then you should look at chicken
chicken is the the number one farmed
animal on the planet there's there's
billions and billions of them uh killed
every single year for food and that
takes up a lot of cropland and that
brings a host of other issues too that
brings the issues of antibiotic
resistance because a lot of these
animals in confinement they require
antibiotics and if you keep pumping
Animals full of antibiotics there's all
kinds of risks that will come from uh
antibiotic resistance bacteria which is
essentially just the possible reality of
the future where antibiotics just don't
work
um so that's a bit outside of the
environmental sphere but it's a huge
problem with confining animals it's all
tied together yeah exactly so
um so this is what we've done to our
planet is we've uh kind of got rid of a
lot of wild species only four percent of
the biomass of all animals on the planet
are wild the rest are humans and
domesticated animals so first we need to
shift away from animal uh Source Foods
that's a very big number like it's a
huge number a lot of people probably do
not realize that that's huge yeah so
think like you think of Wild Spaces
there's less and less of it the biggest
erosion of Wild Spaces the biggest
driver of biodiversity loss is animal
agriculture this is documented in tons
of studies tons of analyzes of what's
driving biodiversity collapse even
groups like The World Wildlife Fund
which hasn't has kind of shied away a
little bit of talking about food is now
coming around to saying yeah this is the
main driver of biodiversity collapse so
um I think first we need to look at this
uh type of food and we can talk about
ways we can kind of shift off that after
but I think first we need to look at
animals uh and have more Wild Spaces
re-wild and and allow native wild
species to return
then we should be looking at kind of
reducing the industrial plant
agriculture model as well when we're
looking at monocultures of this team
crop uh that are kind of genetically
modified to to allow things like Roundup
and glyphosate to be sprayed I think
that's a big issue too mostly for the
people farming people farming that are
exposed to to
Roundup is it's a it's a major major
issue but I think we first need to
understand that a lot of those feed
crops are feed crops a lot of those
crops that are grown are specifically
for confined animals so if you dress
that first thing you're already
addressing that second thing if you
address animal Source Foods you're
already addressing the industrial plant
agriculture model
a lot of people kind of pit the two
against each other like it's
monocultures and plant-based foods and
uh local small uh ranches it's not the
case like these go together well I guess
they're kind of thinking that they're
you're shifting away from that
industrialized animal agriculture model
if you're doing the grass-fed model so
they are thinking that they're shifting
away from that as well so is that not
kind of valid a lot of them are still
supplemented from crops from off farm so
a lot of those grass finish models still
have supplementation of monocultures of
hay for example so uh even with a
grass-finished model there's still Lots
even will Harris's firm he had lots of
inputs from off Farm like what uh so in
his case there was inputs for uh a lot
of the mono gastric animals that are on
there so chickens and pigs he said in
the bait that they've shifted a bit away
from chickens uh I don't think that's
necessarily because the chicken model
was not working well in in their case
there uh they had a lot of issues with
bald eagles that were eating the the
chickens wow and there's nothing they
could do about that because it's a
protected and dangerous species uh so
you know over time they had to find
different ways of kind of hazing and
keeping bald eagles away but ultimately
they just had to shift away from that
chicken model but yeah there are lots of
crops brought from uh off farm for that
which then is kind of turned into manure
and then goes into the land so that does
add some carbon to the land but it's
from off Farm
um so yeah then uh with plant
agriculture there's many ways of doing
it eco-friendly uh there's many ways of
Shifting away from those synthetic
fertilizers
um it doesn't have to be full kind of
veganic models but you can be lowering
the inputs of manure and lowering the
inputs of synthetic fertilizers simply
by composting more simply by planting
cover crops and what I mean by that is
you're growing certain crops in between
other crops and then letting that fall
down to the ground that protects the
soil that protects like as soon as
you're covering the soil you're going to
have less soil erosion so and that is
part of regenerative agriculture as a
whole that's something that is a solid
kind of foundation of that type of model
so I think that can happen a lot more in
kind of plant agriculture as a whole
um you know fruit trees across the world
fruit trees would be a phenomenal thing
as well because they can grow on kind of
what they call marginal land that can
grow in degraded soil and and produce
some good nutrients back for for local
areas
um I think we should be looking at the
planet and determining where the best
areas for agriculture are and that's
shifting as our planet is warming it's
it's kind of Shifting to different areas
but we should look at where the best
areas of growing food is and have some
sort of like just Eco uh distribution of
food across the world almost like a an
agreement as a basic right because there
should be no people around the world
that should not have access to healthy
foods so there needs to be more of kind
of a collaboration around the world
which is a difficult thing these days
but there needs to be more collaboration
with different countries that can grow
different foods and I think
technology as well is going to play a
little bit of a role in this kind of
future food system
um in just the last few years Precision
fermentation cultivated meat plant-based
products they're all going to add to
this scenario where you can still be
growing crops in an eco-friendly manner
but also allowing some countries that
were never really exporters of crops to
start producing their own so look at
Precision fermentation Precision
fermentation you're you're essentially
growing uh the the protein like say the
milk protein
um through uh microbial uh um processes
and you can do this in countries that
are in the far north you can do this in
countries that are in the far south
areas that never necessarily produce a
whole lot of food themselves but uh they
could have this in a decarbonized manner
so it's from the solar panels and wind
farms and suddenly they're able to
produce a lot of the food themselves and
uh you know I wrote a kind of a a piece
on what the food system could look like
in uh in 2030 and uh this plays a factor
for sure
yeah interesting so do you think let's
say we're taking these Farmers that are
growing monocrops what they should do
instead you mentioned a few things like
cover crops and things like that but
would it be sustainable and possible for
them to do things like a small farming
system does or like a backyard farming
is that even possible to be able to grow
a wide variety of things or is that just
economically not even feasible to do
that in a large scale so that they're
doing all different kinds of plant crops
within their Farm I mean there's a lot
of uh depending where you're in the
world there's a lot of issues with that
because there's a lot of risk the
farmers take on and they shouldn't
necessarily but I think we should first
acknowledge that a lot of farming right
now is from big huge companies there's
there's very little small farmers
anymore but they still have that kind of
Ideal like image of that small farmer
but there's very little look at like
chicken breeding there's four companies
in the world that own 99 of all chicken
breeding wow four companies so oh my
goodness um so you think of like a small
chicken farm it doesn't exist it's it's
as much as the person can handle the
firmers there typically are I mean some
countries it's undocumented workers it's
raised specialized people that are
that's the only job that they're able to
do and that's very very unfortunate so
there should be kind of like labor laws
there should be ethical ways to to shift
to more Humane styles of work right
absolutely
um and uh in terms of like farming
better like there needs to be far better
incentives back to that Costa Rica
example we should be having kind of uh
oil gas fossil fuel taxes or some of
that goes towards helping shift
current farming practices to more
eco-friendly firming practices and
current agricultural land to be
reforested and rewilded depending on
what that area is yeah
um there's other examples too like in
the American West uh there's a
documentary called
rewilding a mountain from Dr William
Ripple and others
and in the 90s as well they saw that a
lot of the American West was being
there's a lot of soil degradation from
uh cattle grazing so uh this particular
area they they put a law in place and
they removed all that grazing and
allowed some of the kind of the Native
Antelope and other ruminants to come by
and graze that land and also reintroduce
some of the native animals like the
native Predators like wolves uh across
every area there the land improved the
unfortunate part of that is there's not
a lot of incentives to do that right
this was just a particularly small area
that decided that was a way to restore
that land and it works but there needs
to be incentives to do that otherwise
it'll be a slower shift to get there
otherwise people will just shift that
way when it's like too late when you can
no longer Ranch there you can know like
it's a drought and like that is what's
happening there's lots of firms that are
closing because of a drought and because
of the impacts of climate change and
ecological collapse so so they're
they're forced to kind of transition we
should get ahead of that yeah it's
really it's a really tough conversation
that goes outside the scope of even just
like a College's environmental
understanding because it comes
to capitalism versus socialism big
government versus small government
forcing versus just trying to inspire
people to purchase more skull small
scale farming right like going to your
farmers markets and making that choice
yourself to support the small farmers so
that they have the ability to expand and
continue the way that they're doing it
organically and very um sustainably
versus supporting the big box farming
places that you're going for even plant
agriculture like are you going to Costco
to buy your produce versus are you going
to the farmer's market down the street
but then that also has the question of
people living in places where they don't
have access to a farmer's market so
there's just so many problems and it's
very very difficult to just have the
answer I definitely don't expect you to
have the answer it's just one of those
things that hopefully through people
listening that inspiration can help
people to make the choices that they can
take you know if they do have a farmer's
market let's say it's a little bit
inconvenient it's a little bit farther
than the Costco that's down the street
but it's worth the effort if you care
about the environment you know and
supporting ethical farming so small
scale farming I struggle with the
component of government getting bigger
and stronger and more powerful I don't
love that idea of them having more power
and creating like laws about our food
system more laws about that but I also
see the benefit to protecting the
environment I just don't trust the
government very much that they are
willing to are able to do it yeah that
they're able to do it in a way that
isn't corrupted that they're going to be
influenced by big money that ends up
saying they're protecting the
environment but they're not you know
there's just so many so many factors of
that so I struggled to know too
I think yeah with government and with
huge corporations I think there's a way
in which we can have a food system that
doesn't require either it doesn't need
to be the super small firms uh it can be
a bit more of a balance but certainly
like a decentralized
um mix of cultivated meat Precision
fermentation plant-based products Whole
Food small eco-friendly firms uh and
where none of this is owned by like just
a couple companies yeah but there's a
good mix of sharing among different
countries this may seem kind of
idealistic but I think it's totally
achievable you think it's possible I
like your I like your positive mental
attitude I mean we need it otherwise
like we're gonna we're gonna see that
this was something we needed to do when
it's I wouldn't say too late but almost
too late yeah and then we're scrambling
to try to find a way to put this back in
place yeah and also just the Doom and
Gloom type of conversation is not very
helpful either it's just like oh gosh
there's nothing we can do about this no
yeah you definitely want the positive
attitude about it for sure I struggle
with the cultivated meat thing you've
mentioned a couple times I kind of feel
like it'll just stay on the fringes it's
kind of just the thought of it is really
I think gross to most people all of my
friends who eat animal Foods would never
dare touch that they would never eat the
cultivated meat so I feel like it would
be more of something that only vegans
end up doing and even then vegans won't
want to do it you know what I'm saying
right right uh yeah I'm I feel like with
cultivated meat I can see both sides I
don't have a firm position on it but I
do see where it can play a role
um say McDonald's decides to
pick up cultivated meat maybe uh half of
their Big Macs maybe it's like a it's
like a hybrid right half it's cultivated
meat half fits the normal beat they were
using
um part of the problem there is people
don't know what that looks like people
don't know what the burger at McDonald's
they're getting like how that got there
so if you if if people think that
cultivated meat is more gross uh than
how that got there at that point that I
think that shows some of the
inconsistencies with where we think our
food comes from that's such a good point
people have no clue about the meat
that's in their McDonald's burger they
don't know what happened to that meat
how it got there what it looked like the
sludge that it came into from the
different animals that it you know the
diet all of the stuff that comes into
play with factory farming yes you're
right millions and billions of burgers
they serve yearly right that were half
of it comes from cultivated meat I think
that's where cultivated meat in the
short term may play a role as kind of
these hybrid products because I think
there is some issues with scalability
with cultivated meat
um I don't think it's for vegans I
really don't yeah
um but I see what you're saying like
there is a who's gonna buy it there is a
branding issue there is an issue because
because when you think of lab food
disgusting yeah yeah of course I get it
um and it's I'm also skeptical I I feel
like science has its limitations and the
claims that it could just be identical
is also just gross to me and also I
don't know there's just everything about
it that at least everyone in my circle I
don't know anybody in my circle who
would eat that even people who eat me
because because they're sourcing like
regenerative and they definitely don't
think like lab grown anything is going
to be better for themselves but I think
that you make an interesting point about
the something like McDonald's where it's
people who are purchasing that don't
really care where the food is coming
from I mean maybe that's a big a big
thing I mean like in the U.S 99 of all
food comes from factory farms uh
globally it's about 90 so I think once
people understand what Factory firm is
in terms of what food and where that
comes from having it come from uh you
know not a massive like a local scale
cultivated meat Brewery tank like uh
you're talking like beer breweries right
people like going to like a local
microbrewery right and see that as
something that's possible I don't think
it's so far-fetched that we can change a
perception of those things now I'm not
saying this is like going to be the
future because the future of food yeah I
think I think it'll play a role and I
think it'll be a positive step in the
right direction because it's going to
allow us to rewild the planet if this
does if this is successful yeah so it
should at least deserve a little bit of
funding to try it out yeah
um like during your debate uh there was
a number of things that came up around
you know funding uh Jason mentioned that
you know eat Lancet is a group that I
cited a couple times and how they've
received funding as well to promote uh
more of a plant-based or plant
predominant type diet uh I did the quick
math on this on the subsidies and the
financial institutions of how much money
is going where
uh one percent of the funding for
agriculture as a whole is going towards
these plant-based products Precision
fermentation and cultivated meat uh
we're talking 400 and something billion
is going towards animal Source Foods
that's insane and that's just from
financial institutions subsidies as well
uh there was a recent study that showed
90 of all subsidies across the world are
farming are are subsidizing destruction
so destructive firming practices so I
mean shifting subsidies that's a very
complicated thing I think we kind of
better off incentivizing new forms
because that's kind of like the the
carrot versus the stick type thing if
you incentivize you're more likely to
get changed versus uh penalizing people
for doing certain things
but at the same time it's government
money that's being funded towards these
industries that are home to our health
and to our environment it makes
absolutely no sense that we're not
having more of our subsidy money going
towards healthy plant foods to make
healthy food affordable to people
especially people who struggle to get
food on the plate you know on their
plate for their family so they're going
to choose the McDonald's burger or over
the head of broccoli that cost the same
amount of money so that subsidy issue is
so huge and it's something that I'm very
surprised that
uh political discussions are not they're
not having that discussion on either
side of the aisle you know Democrat
Republican anything they're not they're
not having this discussion about food
subsidies that's so hugely important and
I really wish that were that were
happening to put push a little put a
little bit of pressure on that because
it would make such a difference if
healthy food was more affordable and
also would be better for the planet
because some people would choose that
more and then that that is the natural
incentive for the for us as a consumer
to choose something that is more
affordable so if the government did that
alone that would be the natural
incentive I think yeah like there's some
people of course that are only focusing
on the taste and the price because those
are mostly the drivers of why people
choose to eat what they eat is the price
and The Taste and animal Source Foods do
not reflect the price that they should
reflect they should be far higher not
even close not even close can you break
down the numbers a little bit for that
there was a so let me give one example
in New Zealand uh in New Zealand they
have a company called fontera it's one
of the biggest uh Dairy companies in the
world they export more Dairy than
anywhere else in the world
uh there's a recent analysis of
externalities externalities is like an
economic environmental term where uh
those are the prices that are pushed
onto Society so with a dairy firm in New
Zealand there's lots of runoff into
waterways
that Dairy company is not covering the
cost of the damage there uh there's
there's a study that looked in this case
of the waterways next to pastoral
settings in New Zealand and over 90
percent of them you could not swim in
wow because there's so much runoff from
the manure from dairy farms so that's an
externality that should be factored in
the price and what they found is
um not only is it the one of the major
drivers of greenhouse gases in New
Zealand but if you factor in these other
issues uh and you kind of restore the
ecosystem that would bring more economic
benefits and revenues than actually
exporting that as one of the largest
dairy exporters in the world so there
just needs to be a realignment of kind
of incentives there and like you said
before kind of like just incentivizing
healthy plant Foods this should be a
win-win people should you know be
excited and happy about paying less for
fruit to vegetables high proteins this
is this is a good way to shift that
should have kind of common common
support but I do see what you said about
not wanting to punish the farmers by
taking away their subsidies but at the
same time would they be able to shift
what they're doing because I have seen
there are some animal Farmers that are
switching to plant agriculture how hard
is that and how feasible is that for
farmers
I I think there's some Farmers that are
totally willing to take on the financial
risk of doing that I think some of that
is a cultural and social pressure right
so there there is like a cohesiveness to
uh people that are ranching and people
that are doing that so I can totally
respect that I understand that there is
a lot of socioeconomic considerations
with all this
um I think the financing will help and
that'll be a first place to start to
incentivize just like what happened in
Costa Rica incentivize farming better
incentivizing rewilding uh will be a
great kind of First Step yeah okay so
let's get into specifically about
regenerative farming for animal
Agriculture and you know grazing animal
grazing and grass-fed Dairy the claims
made that they are going to be the
environment you have touched a lot on it
but what are the strengths and what are
the weaknesses specifically let's go on
let's go to Dairy first
so Dairy is an interesting one there's
not tons of cases where there's
so-called regenerative Dairy part of the
reason is because whenever you're
shifting Dairy to kind of more of a
grass finish system you're producing far
far less milk and when you're producing
far far less milk uh per liter it's it's
way more intensive for the environmental
impacts so there's a couple of cases
where that's happening but the the price
is higher the environmental impacts are
higher across the board with ranching
it's a little bit different because the
the trade-offs that are most visible
would be typically there's less soil
degradation there's less intensive
grazing or there's more kind of managed
different fences of the land where
they're grazing at one time
um but like I mentioned before there's
more methane with both those cases in
the organic setting so you think of
organic you think it's going to be
better in many cases it's not in many
cases with the animal Source food it's
higher in methane higher in land use
water is about the same depending on how
much water you're going to bring in so
how much of a drought setting that that
is where it's being organically firmed
but those trade-offs you if you really
want to ship towards regenerative
agriculture that uses more land you
really got to compare it to the land
that that's displacing
and if you're at least saying okay we
should be producing less animal Source
foods and what's left we do this way so
we can maybe do it longer that's where
you can kind of get you can kind of make
sense I can understand that because
we're not going to just get everyone to
stop farming animals I got told to get
that that's going to be a process but we
need to kind of understand that there's
some uh physical limits to our planet
and there's limits to how much
destruction we're going to provide right
so why do why do people think that if
they go to their local Dairy their local
Dairy they're getting raw milk from a
grass-fed Dairy why do they feel like
that's better for the environment and
why is it not
I mean put simply I think this is
decades and decades and Decades of
lobbying subsidies and misinformation I
think this is this is a story that's
been told for for many many years and
um and marketed to to look that way it's
the perfect marketing tool this like
Lush uh local firm supporting uh uh
someone in the local region but the
reality especially now is far far
different most of times these are these
are massive companies
um and if it is a local kind of raw
dairy then it feels kind of elitist
honestly it's kind of like okay in this
case you're able to get it this way but
is this something that's going to be
feeding the world
um I get that you can kind of source it
in that way but you're still displacing
something you're displacing Wildlife
you're displacing an ecosystem you could
be shifting towards plant-based milks
which type of fraction of all
environmental impacts
so I think
you know I don't buy that scenario that
there is better and you know some people
promote the message of kind of less and
better
but what happens when you promote the
kind of less and better meat that is is
you focus too much on the better
not on that first kind of less message
and if you do focus on that then you can
start seeing okay there's some options
that can be better on the smaller scale
on the smaller amounts you're eating a
very little amount yeah and when you
explain how the grass-fed dairy cows are
having even less milk they're producing
even less milk
how does that work when people are
thinking that grass-fed Dairy is more
ethical so I know that you're this is
we're talking about the environment but
that if that means that it's even less
milk and are they keeping the baby cows
the calves with the mother is that the
case or are they actually still take
removing the cat the baby caps do you
know I mean it might depend on which
case you're talking about there but
there would be some ethical improvements
there but I don't think you can look at
that in isolation I think you also need
to look at the ethical nature of
wildlife yeah the ethical nature of uh
rewilded areas of land returning some
land Back To Nature I think there's just
as much ethical arguments there oh yeah
yeah so because you're taking even less
milk so even if you're keeping the baby
calf with the cow there's so little milk
that you're getting from that so you
need even more lands to get to get what
you're trying to get which is the milk
yeah that's so interesting and
fascinating I think people just aren't
looking at they're not looking at the
bigger picture you're right they're just
walking up to the farm and it's oh look
at this pretty farm this little it's
local the word local and you know all
that makes it seem like it's good and
it's right and it's back the way that
our you know our grandparents used to do
it yeah not realizing the the impacts
that
My overall kind of conversations with
people about this too I have friends as
well that will Source from uh you know
the farmers market local beef local
Dairy things like that uh the
conversations I try to have with those
people are not
polarizing ones they're not ones where
I'm looking to be right I'm trying to
understand by asking questions I'm
trying to understand like why it is
they're choosing that in a
non-judgmental way yes and that could be
difficult I've learned over time of how
to do that better right yeah but um I
think even in those cases where people
want to Source from someone they know
who might serve uh you know the the raw
milk even if you can get past the
nutritional issues of that like of
course there is some risk of salmonella
and things like that when you're
choosing that but
um the overall bigger picture is what
I'm really interested in and I'm
interested okay if they're doing that
are they shifting more towards
plant-based Foods as well and if they
are maybe their diet is like 80 90
plant-based yeah I think that's great
yeah I think we need a lot of people
just doing better I don't think we need
a lot of people being perfect yeah um
and there's no perfect anyways no even
like looking at the the environmental
impacts of everyone's personal lives
there's always somewhere where you're
going to be deciding where you're going
to use like your carbon footprint but I
think there's some general things that
that we should be aware of that have the
biggest kind of benefits and food is one
of the biggest ones especially
personally you don't always have control
over the energy that you're country or
Province or state will supply and you
might not be able to afford solar panels
or wind farms depending on where you're
in the world you have a lot more
autonomy over what you choose to eat and
uh if we can make that easier if we can
make that more affordable uh make you
know eating plant-based delicious and
cool because it is like that's where I
think we're going to get a lot more
benefits and again people are going to
be trying to be perfect people can just
be kind of Shifting towards the best
they can yes I love that I'm so glad you
said that speaking of perfection a
criticism that a lot of people get who
are vegan
that we're killing more animals through
plant Agriculture and through plant
harvesting that animal more animals are
dying in the harvesting of our plants
than if you just ate the meat directly
grass-fed meat so can you touch on that
one yeah so I will go back to the feed
conversion loss situation there so when
you take 100 calories of grain and you
feed it to a chicken you're only going
to get 12 calories back in in meat so
you're gonna have about a 90 loss in
crops so even if you thought even if
you're believing that there's more
animals that die in a plant monoculture
you'd still be better off eating less
meat so even if that was true that
there's more kind of small rodents and
and small little animals that might be
dying in a in a monocult crop field
there still would be less monocultures
if we shift it away from animal Source
Foods uh now if someone is only eating
grass finish regenerative beef and
they're not even eating any chickens or
pigs or anything like that right then in
that situation you're gonna your actual
land footprint of your diet is so huge
that then you're killing way more
Wildlife or you're preventing that
wildlife of returning to that area of
land so this kind of narrative that more
animals die in a plant-based diet it's
made up it's made up based on a story
it's made up based on this kind of false
dichotomy of monocultures versus local
small ranches and it feeds into this
kind of story and narrative that is
captivating but there's very little
science to support it and uh yeah I'd
say call out that BS because there's
just so much of that going around yes
that's really fascinating now what about
grass-fed beef can we get a little bit
more into that one
so there was a study in the United
States from a researcher at Harvard and
Boston University that showed if we did
not reduce beef consumption and shifted
from the feedlot model to Grass finished
you'd use up to 270 percent more land
than the feedlot model and that's not
including the regenerative model that
uses 2.5 times more land or some Jason
Roundtree study so uh there's simply not
enough land to do this and on a global
level there's been kind of models that
looked at if we take that standard
American diet that is high in animal
Source foods and it's continued to be
exported to different countries you
would need seven Earths to actually firm
that way so we're at like a critical
point in time where we have a decision
to make do we want this kind of standard
American diet that you know has lots of
issues overall but also is high in
animal sourced foods and we want that
exported around the world or do we now
want to decide okay how can we do this
better
how come how can other countries how can
we help them learn from the mistakes
that we made in these rich countries and
uh provide them with you know Equitable
healthy plant Foods
um as they become richer too and I think
that's going to involve a lot of
collaboration between different
countries
um but the alternative would be far
worse the alternative is is more
ecosystem destruction uh you know the
climate crisis that is amplifying
drought and uh you know climate refugees
moving all around the world so we're
going to need kind of collaboration to
address this but if we don't the
consequences will be far worse yeah so
even though there's kind of like these
socioeconomic considerations of like say
Will Harris and his firm and what would
incentivize him to kind of rewild some
of that land we should we should
consider that for sure and there needs
to be conversations that are had there
but we also need to picture the issues
will be far worse in a in an ecological
collapse that we're facing in the coming
decades so we need to start shifting in
ways that are yeah are better there
outside this conversation that we had
with Jamie videlli Jason Roundtree and
while Harris is so important because if
you guys could have gotten on the same
page at least about the part about
eating less animal foods like Hey we're
in support of if you're doing this in a
way where we're telling people okay if
you're gonna eat it then this this would
be the way because it's better but let's
do less like having that type of
um slogan and being on the same team
there that could be something that would
be
something our our land in the U.S could
do and could bear if we all were
collectively having that understanding
and that message because it would be
better if we were all eating directly
from our own land supporting our own
um environmental footprint and not
having to Outsource even you know
because if more people are eating
plant-based we would require less land
and we wouldn't have to Outsource so
much yeah so there's that aspect too so
what is the best diet for our planetary
Health do in regards to the amount of
meat when you were calling for a
reduction how significant of a reduction
are we talking can you give a little bit
more specifics for people so they can
know how big of a reduction would make
an impact
so I'm going to refer to some kind of
studies that looked at this there was a
study that looked at rich countries only
and in terms of the global population
it's actually only 17 of the global
population so not a a large amount of
people if we shifted about 80 to 90
percent plant-based diets it would free
up an extreme amount of land we'd be
talking uh several not billion hectares
of land we're talking like areas the
size of the entire continent of Africa
that we could rewild and that is not
even addressing the areas of the planet
where they might be uh you know having
like a pastoral setting of farming meat
and dairy just because they're meeting
basic needs we're talking rich countries
only privileges areas of the world that
can reduce and can shift towards options
have those options in the area they
still should be more
economically feasible but um but yeah if
you just do that then about 89 would
totally be be fine and when you say 80
90 is that 90 of calories or 90 of your
plate
um overall Foods so more plant-based
Foods yeah so um yeah I mean if you look
at per plate just like a very small
amount of it dedicated towards towards
me but I mean for me uh I would rather
just do it fully yeah based totally yeah
um and and like for me like I ate the
typical uh standard American diet it's
in a Canadian diet where I am and
um it wasn't until I looked at this
topic my Master's where I really felt
like a bit of a hypocrite right I felt
like uh there was so many things I was
aware of I was aware of the impact of
fossil fuels I was aware of
deforestation but I wasn't putting these
dots together
and I think that's the case with a lot
of people I think the the food topic and
the food and environment topic has
really only been kind of brought to a
bit more mainstream in the last like
decade or so yeah and maybe in the last
few years so you know I think just
talking about this issue talking about
the many solutions and the ways in which
we can we can improve it is is a big
thing and meeting people where they are
planting seeds with different people
without kind of breaking relationships
over this thing yes right I think that's
the way to go and when people are
choosing more plants over animal foods
does it really matter any plants or or
is it like could it be processed foods
Ultra processed foods that are all
plant-based or are we thinking you need
to be eating more whole plant Foods what
is what is better for the environmental
impact and also feasible I know we're
taking into account that that's what's
what's feasible too but yeah so I think
when it comes to the best option it'd be
Whole Food plant-based that's best for
your health that's best for the planet
the planet the planetary aspect of that
would be because you're relying Less on
oils
seed oils now I don't think there's a
big health issue with that I don't think
there's a major environmental issue with
that but if you are shifting from like a
processed plant-based diet to a whole
food plant based diet or mostly you're
going to get a slight Improvement in
health and or probably a lot more in
health than your environment
but if you were to take the current diet
and shift it fully to a slightly more
processed plant-based diet there would
still be huge improvements you would you
could free Up 3 billion hectares of land
if we hypothetically did this on the
global scale so as much as I I don't
want that to happen yeah I think we
still need to be aware that if we did go
to that scenario we're not just it's not
just a trade-off it is still a
significant Improvement in land
greenhouse gases water
and if we then do that then we address
kind of the the issues of uh you know a
few companies owning all these if we
then look at shifting more towards Whole
Food plant-based diets from there I
think that'd be good too so yeah because
I think a lot of people think well if I
stop if I don't support the animal Foods
here but if I buy this Ultra processed
packaged food here I'm still supporting
the industrialized crop farming so I'm
not really having a good I'm not having
a good trade-off there but what you're
saying is that the animal Foods take up
so do so much land and so much of the
crop farming that even if you're
choosing the plant-based food that is
you know industrialized cropping crop
farming it's a much smaller amount
totally because the amount of calorie
conversion that you're getting yeah
that's that's fascinating so let's say
someone wants to do this and they're
going to choose more plant-based Foods
what else can they do to support their
environmental impact oh there's so much
stuff
um I think composting at home is
important uh I think shifting away from
plastic use is important uh you know
reducing waste overall I think talking
about it with family friends talking
about the environmental issues you're
seeing and what you're doing I think is
important because this kind of
normalizes that conversation
um I think you know there's a big
pressure on it being like an individual
thing but ultimately it's both there's a
little bit of an individual thing but
it's a systemic issue too especially
when it comes to energy use and fossil
fuel use that is something that you
should be you know talking with local
politicians people in your community
about ways in which we can decarbonize
um you know for me I you know I'm not a
perfect environmentalist of course like
but I like to try to live minimally uh
this kind of consumer lifestyle of
buying everything on Amazon and just
showing up at your doorstep there's
conveniences to it but there's a huge
environmental impact to it as well and
when you do these things when you're
shifting to more kind of like an
eco-friendly lifestyle it doesn't lower
happiness like it doesn't lower your
well-being in many ways it uh it kind of
you know grounds people and makes people
a lot more appreciative of of the planet
so uh yeah I think I think living by
example is good I think advocating and
talking about these things educating
yourself on the different things you can
do
um
when it comes to like kind of
Transportation so a little bit outside
of energy but getting around
uh I mean I'm a huge fan of biking
biking around but of course if your
City's not set up to have safe areas
where you can bike around bike Lanes uh
if you're driving on the shoulder of the
road I don't blame the person for that
yeah you want to be safe right yeah so
uh like where I live there's lots of
bike Lanes now but some of them don't
even connect so like I mean I do it
because maybe I'm just kind of stubborn
I just want to buy tomorrow
I know yeah but uh but I think you know
that's a you know having active
Transportation having cities designed
better to promote these things this is
what's called like um it's kind of like
a behavioral nudge there's lots of signs
around this to show that if you set up
Society to make the easiest choice the
eco-friendly one so that could be for
biking that could be for
um taking public transit if it's a good
experience right instead of it being not
so good of experience when it comes to
food if the the tastiest cheaper option
it's a plant-based option people just
intuitively choose that option so
there's you know that's not going to
solve all the issues but that will solve
some of the big issues of first uh
normalizing it more in society and I
advocate for that a lot because this is
one of the first things that we can do
that has quite a bit of political
support
um just in terms of it being like a
well-being promoting thing it being a
personal action that you know it's it's
more easier for people to make
so yeah behavioral nudges is a big one
when it comes to food when it comes to
Transportation energy too and those are
some things people can do love it those
are that's all really helpful and I just
love picturing you on your bike like
like getting yourself to go those places
that are harder to navigate but you're
like it's worth it I know yeah so to
finish this conversation can you just
paint a picture of the way agriculture
used to look like to what it looks like
today because I think that's really
helpful for people to just understand
that it didn't always look like this and
what did it look like before totally yes
so uh in the 60s uh there was actually
quite a bit of farmed animals still 8
billion
um but there was more of a pastoral
setting and from the 60s what we did is
we uh intensified the whole process we
can find more animals we grew all kinds
of feed crops and we allowed them to get
to like a Slaughter weight very quickly
but that came with a host of many many
issues uh now there's two narratives
today there's a narrative well we should
go back to that model where there's more
pastoral setting
but that's going to use firm or land
that's not something we can do anymore
we need to instead look at ways that we
can uh do conservation agriculture on a
small amount of land and uh and grow
plants and make it great to grow plants
and eat plants and I think that's the
way we need to shift towards looking
back at kind of like you know The
Narrative of ancestral diets in in paleo
and keto this is something that
um you know it's it's all part of this
narrative that
um that we need to shift back to how it
was and I don't think I don't think
that's what we need to do I think we do
need to shift towards kind of Whole Food
plant-based diets but I think technology
can play a role in helping people eat
what they love to eat eat in a way that
it's
um economically good for them too and
health promoting and welcome space for
wildlife and nature and I think it's a
combination of kind of the the natural
Whole Food way but also some plant-based
products that will fit in there as well
yeah and I think that's a good way to go
so good I love this conversation thank
you for being here and
we're gonna end it here thanks so much
thanks so much all right bye
foreign
[Music]